what aren't we listening to
when i say you aren't listening it's
because
i don't want to talk about things that
don't matter
and everything is asked except for
why are you protesting they'll ask you
you know what do you think about the
troops
it's not about the troops it's about
systemic racism it's about lack of
education and lack of equal housing
well what do you think about trump has
nothing to do with him it's all about
our criminal justice system systemic
racism
our school systems and then they'll
continue to go down this road
and the conversation is about everything
but
these issues and so when i say you are
listening it's trying to
force people to deal with what is
actually happening
to real americans on a daily basis
michael smith said we had company of
course we do
malcolm jenkins joins us uh
the pride of the ohio state university i
had to put that in being from the
buckeye state you know i had to get that
shot out there
but but uh malcolm you know we saw an
excerpt there
from some of your work it looks very
powerful uh and interesting what you're
working on
uh just tell us you know tell us what
that's about and and where you are
uh with that with that documentary yeah
so uh i was able to come on
um as an executive producer for black
boys the documentary
really exploring kind of the spectrum of
humanity of black boys
um and and how that humanity oftentimes
is under
attack as early as grade school you know
all the way up through adulthood
um and so we we kind of break down how
the bodies of black boys often times
commodify but we completely
disregard their minds their creativity
their anxieties their trauma their joys
their
pain so i mean oftentimes you know we we
see
in situations like george floyd where
in order to hold somebody hold your knee
on somebody's neck for that long
you have to see them as subhuman or
superhuman
and those two uh you know ideas are
really where we see
black boys and black men being framed
the most when we really need to just be
able to see us
uh as humans and in all of the different
variations that we have
amen um and we see you know the old
spice
uh behind you you are here on behalf of
old spice and their new nfl initiative
helping to implement educational justice
programs in schools based on your
documentary black boys
uh and it's in partnership with never
whisper justice uh
they also produce black boys with you so
what i want to talk about is so did you
do one today because you guys are doing
surprise
virtual school appearances um and
hosting screenings in my hometown of new
orleans for black boys did you
did you surprise any kids today yeah we
did about we uh
drop in on about three different schools
man it went awesome you know the kids
were very very engaged they had
questions
they were able to watch the film
beforehand and we were able to talk
about some of those things
and you know i was able to ask them
questions like what are some of the
things that
resonated with you and in one of the
sessions they talked
about uh this idea of society fearing
you
when they don't even know who you are uh
and and what that
feels like you know and how they
internalize that and so the message to
me
you know that i try to repeat to them is
that you know we
are we know as black men and black boys
that we are fully human
that we deserve every right that any
other human being does that there is
nothing to be afraid of
you know us for and it is not our job to
to make other people comfortable or
shrink ourselves
in order to fit into this society and so
we have to break down first like we
can't believe the lies that society
tells about us
or tells us about ourselves then we have
to boldly kind of walk in our own
greatness
you know love it you know you know
what's so interesting malcolm uh you
know the three of us here
we were all all obviously uh black boys
dealing with some of the things that
you're bringing up here whether it's uh
fears our hopes our joys our our
insecurities
and all three of us are our storytellers
so
when did you think about combining your
experience
as a black boy now a black man and and
your
um love of storytelling when did you
start thinking about putting these
things together
uh i really came out of a frustration
you know with the whole
nfl and social justice kind of things
over the last four or five years
the narrative that players were trying
to get out they've been hijacked and
co-op
um and so being able to own your own
voice and your own narrative and telling
your own stories was the motivation for
me to start listening up media which is
my
production company and black boys is the
first project that we've been able to
come on as an executive producer and i
think it's very very important
especially in this moment
that we are able to tell our own stories
because
our history you know the dialogue uh
oftentimes
uh has been told about us but not from
us
amen um that frustration
i will stay with that theme for a second
just obviously we started a season
coming off of uh the the racial
the so-called racial reckoning in this
country uh experienced this
this offseason we see you know in racism
it takes all of us
psas there was something of a roll call
especially week one
everybody in the media was more enamored
with who did what versus
as you've been saying versus the why
just where do you think the so-called
conversation is right now specifically
as it relates to to pro football's role
in that conversation
yeah i think we've been having the
conversation for about four years now
and it's time to move past the
conversation whenever you get to the
point where
it's it's ease like you looking now you
know the nfl is promoting
you know players that are raising their
fists that are taking knees
um where it was the total opposite just
a few years ago
so now that it's safe and it's cool that
means that we've already
brought the awareness you know we've
done that we've created awareness now
where's the action
and not just cutting checks and not just
the
statements and the hashtags but like how
are we being politically active how are
we
you know helping people get ready to
participate in this election how are we
using the leverage that we have as nfl
players as nfl
owners and as a league to push for
different policy changes
uh because we know that they lobby when
it's their business interest
but how are they using that same
leverage to um
you know to push forward the same
communities that they use
uh to make money and drive their league
and i think that's where
players need to continue to push the
envelope in that space we've seen it at
very
small some small examples but there's so
much opportunity i think for this league
to
take a leadership role in really pushing
for policy changes
where do you think the league is we were
talking about this before you came on um
i think the last time i saw you mike was
saying the last time he saw it last time
i saw you was out at harvard
uh you were out there with devin
mccourty uh and others
we were talking about police brutality
and implicit bias and a lot of other
things that we continue to talk about
today but
uh jason mccordy said the nfl really
doesn't care about us
talking about covid and the approach
there how do you feel
the league is doing with protocols and
just when when somebody tests positive
moving a game postponing a game do you
agree with with jason mccordy
that there's not enough caring from the
nfl on this
well i think we'd be foolish to believe
that the nfl cares more about
our safety than they do about their
profits not to say that they don't care
about our safety
uh because i think that the protocols
that we have in place
and the things that we've done all kind
of offseason uh have been a work in
progress and contain
you know collaboration with the nfl pa
so they've been working with players but
obviously their bottom line
is the main you know priority and i
think everybody who came into this at
least the understanding was that
you know we're trying to play football
in a pandemic
no amount of protocols is going to make
this completely safe there's going to be
guys who get
the uh who contract kovi and there there
might be guys who spread it
but are we doing as much as we can to
to you know eradicate uh or stop
you know the spread and and make it
through the season that's really the
goal how do we make it through the
season knowing that those protocols
will probably change as the virus
changes um
so i think it's a a tough space but i
think
we've done as much as we can do uh as a
league
and a union to make this the protocol
safe but we are trying to play
sports in a non-essential business
during a pandemic
um we'll give i want to get on the field
in a minute uh you know the last night's
game thank you for joining us today
after a game
um a late game at that um i
i this isn't so much of a question it's
just observation man obviously you know
we've known each other for a while i got
a number of respect for you and the work
that you do
some that's always frustrated me is
how we as black people are charged
with fixing a problem that we didn't
create you know you guys as athletes are
you know whenever you speak up for
social injustice
or racial justice you're told to get in
your communities and
and what are you doing you know what i
mean and yet malcolm
you are doing the work and what's
fascinating about this specific work and
again black boys is streaming
exclusively on peacock check it out it's
very very powerful
you know you're here for old with old
spice who announced a 10-year initiative
to help increase high school graduation
rates by 10 through confidence and
empowerment programs
i really want to hone in on what we
talked about earlier with you speaking
to these kids
and showing them a move a film
that highlights and celebrates their
humanity
i guess again sorry i hope you follow my
train of thought but
how do you balance like i said
trying to try to work to solve a problem
that you didn't create
but yet you're finding constructive
strategies maybe that's what i'm looking
for constructive strategies
to really from the inside uplift
empower you know and educate these young
people
but also just like help them to
celebrate their own humanity like you
said earlier see them
differently than the way society sees
them am i making sense
yeah i think there's two sides to it
right there's you know
with in your own house right i look at
like black people what can we be doing
for ourselves
and the biggest thing is we need to
protect ourselves from the messages that
we get
about ourselves from as early as you
know kindergarten all the way up through
we need to continue to reinforce that
like we are more than just athletes and
entertainers
we you know have always been
intellectuals we have always been
creators
always have pushed our society forward
but then there's the other part of it
when we talk about policy change how do
we actually move the hurdles and change
uh the actual obstacles that are in in
front of black boys and black people
but those policies aren't for black
people because we understand fully
who we are that we're human and deserve
everything
the policies are to tell everybody else
why
whoever else you know that that you must
treat us this way
and so you know i think that's the way
to frame kind of how i balance those
things
the policy changes for black people
they're for everyone else who do not
acknowledge
that black people do not agree that
black people deserve
the full rights of citizenship and the
full rights of their humanity
you know it's such a great point did you
bring up i remember and i'm glad you
brought it up too
uh mike smith you know i remember um
martin luther king talking about uh in
one of his sermons he was talking about
how he was in jail and he started
talking with
those who were outside the jail white
people and he was talking with them he's
in jail
and he starts talking to them about
their salaries and he said oh that's how
much money you make
you need to be out here protesting with
us so i think with
it's funny when you bring up policies
unfair policies they're not just unfair
policies
for black people but if you really think
about the policy you say why does this
exist in the united states that sign you
held up when you said you're not
listening
you talked about people killed by police
and the number eight percent there was
eight percent then there was 25 percent
right so 25 percent
killed by police that means other people
were killed by police too so police
brutality is a problem
it's a problem for us disproportionately
but you bring up the point
these are issues that we all should be
talking about
yeah i think you know the issues that we
we we
talk about and target black people
because when you look across the board
whether it's education criminal justice
and uh healthcare
all of these these things black people
are usually getting the short end of the
stick
you know in all of those across the
board so when we begin to pump resources
in those spaces there are also other
people who
who are being victimized as well and so
you raise the bar for
us you raise the bar for everybody so we
talk about poverty and doing things to
eradicate poverty
black people are not the only poor
people out there you know so all
of these things have a they not only
help black people who have been
historically disenfranchised and
marginalized
but they help us as an entire society
because there are a ton of us that have
the same issues and share uh the same
plight
trying to live you know what we
you know uh think the american dream is
i guess we gotta talk football we can
just stay here all the time but i
haven't gotta kind of get about football
we don't necessarily
but we eventually have to let him go and
i do want to ask you a couple of
football questions we can do this all
day though man
uh right yo you got a little salt and
pepper in your beard
your team is about to give you some
serious but you about to get some
serious gray hair
what is it with y'all in these deficits
and these comebacks look i'm from new
orleans you know saints fans nervous are
already bad as it is yeah
what is it about your team man that
y'all find a way to win it may not be
pretty but y'all are finding a way to
overcome these deficits
especially the last couple of weeks yeah
i think you know we have extreme
confidence
as who is in who we are as a team and
where we want to go
um but one thing that we understand
about this league is that
you have to one every game is not going
to be pretty you got to find a way to
win
and that's all that matters and i think
there are a lot of things right now
as a team that we're trying to get
corrected uh
you know that the things that we need to
to change if we want to be playing
significant football later in the year
but at the end of the day you got to win
a game and find ways to get out
you know get out of that game with a
victory and that's what we'll continue
to do is always rally
it might not always be pretty but you
know winning wins and losses is all that
matters
yo man thank you for being so available
did you know
before we let you go you might have
heard this already i know if you heard
it last night
in the third quarter last night you
missed your first snap since 2017.
you show up 2006 what was it yeah i'll
ask you that i was sneaking one more
question what was it like for you to
miss a snap for the first time since
2017 last night
i didn't like it i mean i'm
always on the field i've never you know
not been on the field probably since my
rookie year
uh but you know we won the game so that
made me feel better about it
you weren't hurt it was strategic right
you you're good you already know i just
just wasn't on that package in that play
all right we got to talk to sean about
that we can't hear that anymore yeah
hey thank you for being so generous with
your time man thank you we appreciate it
appreciate you guys thank you black boys
streaming
exclusively on peacock hi i'm mike
tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports